does is our tester line hold Dyson
Hoffman says this is unmistakeably as
smart but this has four doors not to
like the standard model and is 80
centimeters longer smart photo smarts
updated 42 has a bigger sibling the new
44 even though they're not quite
identical twins both versions have a lot
in common including a rear engine
smart development chief Marcus wheedle
says the new 44 looks like part of the
family from outside and from the inside
that wasn't really true for the old 44
and the new 44 uses eighty percent of
its exterior length for interior room he
says that's a sensational value which
smart achieved by applying what it had
learned from building tiny cars making
the new for for a real smart shahbaz
Peter josten 44 and akin smart Martin we
are testing the four for prime edition
with a 52 kilowatt three-cylinder engine
this allows very economical driving and
the smart consumes only four point two
liters per 100 kilometers the base price
for the 44 prime edition is thirteen
thousand seven hundred and five euros in
Germany there's a new 5-speed manual and
a twin amex six-speed dual-clutch
transmission to choose from
there are distinctive design features
throughout such as the honeycomb
radiator grille in the front visually
the 44 is very similar to the two-seater
the front and rear overhangs look just
as short even so the roof line of the 44
tapers backwards in a hint of compiling
bass line on says people expect a smart
to be maneuverable and offbeat but also
practical as the name suggests the smart
forfour has four doors but also very
clever interior solutions offering more
stowage space behind the front passenger
seat inside the smart is very modern the
redesigned infotainment center is a new
feature of the familiar Halfmoon
instrument panel and up front the new
city car is both elegant and simple
despite its four seats the car is only
3.4 nine metres long but if you fold
down the seats there's a generous 975
litres of luggage space Marcus says
smart ask customers and potential
customers what they wanted they asked
what keeps you from actually buying the
smart fortwo two-seater and most common
answer was weed lover 42 but with more
space or room for four people so smart
developed the 44 together with the 42
they have the same DNA the certainty
insist faked the after photo the
colorful display unit in the center
console gives the driver access to all
functions such as navigation telephone
and radio
multifunction steering wheel controls
allow information at a glance on the
on-board computer the large displays a
new feature has are the redesigned air
conditioning controls with a base price
of ten thousand nine hundred and ninety
five euros in Germany smart hopes to
conquer the city streets but did it also
win over our tester there for 40 bucks
ein hawd says the 44 is convenient and
fun to drive but it's longer length
means some of the four tues go-kart
feeling is lost but the 44 really has
room for four feel fear it's a near
perfect car for the city due to its
compactness and agility and with ample
cargo volume and space for four adults
the Smart forfour is flexible enough for
urban living